the LA Unified School District doesn't
even try to fire and confident teachers
that's an impossibility but the ones
that are you know credibly accused of
abuse still can take years hi I'm Ted
baliker with Reason TV and today I'll be
sitting down with Stephen greenberg
Greenhut is editor in chief of Cal
watchdog and author of wonders how
public employee unions are rating
Treasury's controlling our lives
bankrupting the nation so tell our
viewers a little bit about Cal watchdog
yeah it's a new nonprofit journalism
Center started in in Sacramento covering
state government figured there's a
little bit to cover up there so we have
a small team of reporters that are
covering some of the stories that get
missed in the in the by the newspapers
newspapers myths stories like it's hard
to believe having been work for a
newspaper for a long time it's just an
effort to well it's an effort to plug in
some of the holes I'm newspapers have
obviously been cutting back and there's
state bureau coverage what kind of
stories do they typically miss well
there's you know and and I don't think
it's all because by any sort of
intention but you know a lot of
newspapers are down to it maybe one
person in their Sacramento Bureau and
the the amount of stories that go on the
type of things that going on the state
capitol there's so many hearings every
day things the deal my reporters come
back every day with issues you know
workers some kind of workers
compensation reform or some kind of new
union featherbedding scheme and there
all sorts of hearings and stories that
go on that just aren't getting covered
just because of a lack of manpower
you're sobering book plunder what's the
gist of it the public employee unions
they've just been having their way with
taxpayers because of the power they have
at the local and state level I watched
it as a columnist and reporter in Orange
County a conservative County and I
watched boards of Supervisors and City
Council's repeatedly increased pension
benefits retro actively for public
employees and we're looking at massive
amount of plunder I mean the average pay
and benefit package for a firefighter in
Orange cow
and it's typical statewide about 175,000
dollars a year in Vallejo the San
Francisco Bay Area city that went
bankrupt because of its excessive pay
and benefit packages for police and fire
it was like 75 80 percent of the budget
we're eating up on those things police
captain's earn of paying benefit package
of $300,000 a year
it's just this one-way ratchet they can
retire after 30 years of pay with 90
percent of their final year's pay at age
50 and and then of course the categories
of Public Safety which get the public
safety get the enhanced benefits so
there's an interesting story behind that
so people think public safety
firefighters cops yeah that's how it
started but that's not what it what is
it now
well milk inspectors I believe are
billboard inspectors they get an
inflated pension benefit and then there
are all sorts of schemes and scams to
boost that final year's pay and of
course according to a lot of study I
mean there's some some varying studies
but a lot a lot of data suggests that
public employees earn sometimes more
often earn more than their counterparts
in the private sector and it used to be
you know the old Deal they used to get
paid last where they get somewhat better
benefits they get more protections and
now they get everything they tend to get
equal or more salary and we could look
at salary schedules I mean look at what
you know a receptionist gets in the
private sector compared to the
government government and then these so
the pay packages are often out of hand
and they often abuse that the overtime
system to to inflate the pay so
sometimes the pay often is far in excess
of what a counterpart might get in the
in the private sector but isn't always
it depends you know
but then the pension benefits are way
better and of course the fewer days of
work and all sorts of job protections
you can't you just can't fire public
employees I mean you have civil service
protections and then union protections
on top of that and all sorts of
seniority rules and so and the
accountability is often very low well
let's get into that that's if you were
to zero in on what are the perks of
being a public employee what are some of
the goodies that you get well one of
them is
you know job security that's unheard of
I mean we're you know you and I am at
will hires I mean if boss comes in and
and they don't like the show right here
I mean that could you know be the end of
the road and it's assumed in civil
service that the employee actually owns
the job and then if they have grievances
you know they have the process they have
to go through to to fire our public
employees ridiculously the LA Times did
a fascinating series on what it takes to
fire misbehaving teachers now court
according to the story I mean the the LA
Unified School District doesn't even try
to fire incompetent teachers that's an
impossibility but the ones that are you
know credibly accused of abuse it still
can take years and they have these
things called rubber rooms where the
teachers sit and they collect their full
pay and salary and and I've seen it well
I've seen it repeatedly with with law
enforcement I mean where the unions
protect even the worst actors and
there's people who misbehave and and
public records are very hard to get in
those kind of kind of instances and
there's there's not a lot of
accountability so those are those are
big things one of the perks that you
mentioned in your book also in the
Reason magazine cover story I should say
this this business of shielded plates
it's that I think that's a perfect a lot
of people may not know about what's the
deal with shielded plates yeah I started
out the book book on with that because
it's not because it's a big problem but
because it's emblematic of the kind of
problem or art at the Orange County
Register the news reporters did a series
and found that I think it's like about 1
million cars on the California Road so
these are private vehicles not state
vehicles have a license plate that the
the private information the home address
is shielded they're in a special
database so we were finding they were
finding that people were driving on the
toll roads and just not paying that the
toll fines and when the toll road
agencies went to send the bill they
couldn't get the addresses in the
process to get the address was so
cumbersome they didn't bother or if our
people with these plates were pulled
over it
triggered it was signal that they were
part of the Brotherhood you know they
were a special member of the protected
class and they would usually would get
professional courtesy which is what
police do with their friends and
neighbors and fellow police officers has
not given them tickets and so so it
turns out that there was a program that
was started back when the Department of
Motor Vehicles used to hand out
addresses and police said you know we
were afraid that somebody's gonna get
our criminals are gonna get our
addresses and track us down so that's
how this private database started but
then it like everything in government
you know it's like rust it never sleeps
so it kept being expanded to one
category of government worker after
another I think if I recall you say it's
something like a million people I mean
it's pretty quiet yeah it's like one out
of 22 vehicles on the road essentially
they could do whatever they want they
could that's you don't have to pay for
tolls probably parking ticket right
right you can just ignore that and it's
it's crazy could you imagine if what the
police would say if what you know there
are one out of twenty two drivers on
there on the road I couldn't couldn't
drive with impunity oh my god it's it's
it's a safety how hazard we need more
rules or we need we need to do something
about it
oh it's police officers and and your
family members driving their own
personal vehicles oh never mind it's
everything's just fine yeah nothing to
see here yeah that's right it's it's
it's just like this is what a touch
there's so many games so many things
that that are played by public employees
and it seemed to go largely unpunished I
mean at the Sacramento Bee reported that
this was in mid 2000s I don't know what
the numbers now but 82% of California
Highway Patrol manager level officers
miraculously discovered a disabling
injury of just almost a year before
retirement which of course that gives
them an extra year off and then protects
50 percent of their fine of their
retirement pay from taxes you know if 82
percent of Reason Foundation employees
discovered a disabling injury it
suggests that there might be some
problem either with the work or some
sort of scam that was being pulled and
then the B story mentioned that the
numbers spiked after CHP got rid of its
fraud division that dealt with us mmm
I don't correlate in there or not but
it's possible